mi piacerebbe tutto un pino perché sa
chi sono io
un po troppo amore nullo perché noi no
logo arrivo vorrei di carte n'è una
anche io però non so se farlo adesso
dopo ti prego adesso ma non so dove
trovare rita la mando io ciccio lo sai
che c'è
io ti voglio un sacco bene quindi
prenditi il mio pene ciccio
ma che fai laggiù a milano io ti aspetto
vieni su ieri
ciccio
direi che possiamo partire da dati
ricordi io sono la nera e tu sei la
bianca ok allora questo gioco per chi
non lo conoscesse e l'abbiamo fatto già
altre volte però mai e ciccio è un gioco
di golf fatto che tu e pietro e pietro
adesso abbiamo evitato che guarda stava
quasi entra entrata è sufficiente un
gioco di golf sono che avevamo fatto io
ciccio e pietro adesso io ciccio e
barbara e proprio ma questa parte veloce
solo per riscaldarci eccoci ci si sta
riscaldando giusto ci credo sto male sto
zitto niente recuperarti impossibile sei
bravissimo però li uccide wow
mi prende per il culo barca è basta ecco
no no no ti prego no agi pace tipografie
brutto fatto niente io tema di fama di
palla ferma rim al fermo di gara veloce
di parlarci ai ok un capitano
riprenderlo tutti i miei punti prima
partita finita questa era per
riscaldamento ragazzi l'ho vinta io pero
proposti da ma la seconda la metto molto
più difficile ci sei
questa partita seria con la
riscaldamento e ora da 21 vinto io ma
questo lo puoi vincere vai
allora ci giochiamo degli iscritti
quanti iscritti
io 30 sono tutti quelli che ai 30.000
attenzione la tocca facciamo sì voglio
essere un pazzo 100.000 20 per cento
mila sì perché sono tanti pro ci provo
ce la giochiamo
l'ex coop come prima come hai preso
fenici così stai zitto tu sai che se
vinci questa partita avrai veramente un
giustifiche allucinante non senti il
peso non senta traguardo 44 ma siamo noi
dobbiamo andare come guarda qua e sotto
la pedrali prima minchia come è
possibile non l'avevo vista neanche per
sbaglio hai fatta sì cerot nuovo ma solo
la è opportuno altri continenti
no si ok ok ma ripari senza pari autore
cito recita ci sta ci sono green dai vai
però questa qua e tu a questo e curling
ci provo per il mediano io non la vedo
un coniglio è in realtà brown è che poi
non vedo manco la linea bianca
ci siamo scontrati vai da cristo vai
no te l'ho centrato anche se non l'ho
centrato non so me l'ha dato anche se
ero io se vi avanti di un punto
i 100mila iscritti sono quasi tuoi kakà
è difficilissimo che facciamo fare si fa
scopro e le viti verso ciò che mi capirà
ancora come tu devi tirare a in via
padova come sa cosa gli incontri a fare
qua ma che devi scendere per tutto si sa
fare il traguardo e poi una volta che
arrivi al traguardo statale jolo io non
ho capito dove stiamo andando ciccio con
lo so e sso scendendo no che figata suo
livello nostro ma dove la bocca scusami
ma basta che arrivati qua e superato di
nuovo
ok è qui che casino cos'è sta roba qua
pompei magnus anche senza voti a devo
tirare in porta di una delle due
credo che le sembro luoghi michele in
porto perché oggi occhi a gigi poi verso
camera parla proprio la mamma mia che
rischio e klose che cosa che c'è una
tensione
weber ha qualche cosa sembra molto di
bronzo perché ho paura ma vabbè tutte
genova ma no ma veramente complimenti
wow pro wein e tiro un milione toriko
già no è staccato gli altri del demonio
basta beh vabbè quanto sta quanto mai
staccato 6 punti tipo sono problemi c'è
poi l'aspetto aspettano
ma grava di forte più forte è cardine 23
visual colori il suo braccio per farti
capire
ok 7 bene 7 tiri sommesso non c'è lo sto
conservato veramente devi fare 12 per
periti recuperi devi fare 12 pro sarà
cosa deve lavarsi a giugno li sento li
sento sono quelli del ricovero questo mi
sto premesse era ora però la perdi 12
ma come si fa a uscire 5a da dietro è
finito e athena dati è perché hai fatto
miss a 14 ma dimettere perché i fatti 12
in totale ma che non vale ma non fase si
vale la regola del magma che ha superato
i tuoi punti di due punti di superata
voce va bene così chi ti piace però vai
bra guadagnati la fama raggiungimi
arrivo c'è già si arrivava come forma 73
punti avanti tre buche tre volte ci si
gioca ancora tutto raggiunti avanti tre
buche ci si gioca paraventi tiro e lo
sapevo e quando c'è male non so quanti
tentativi miliardi ci vorranno per fare
questa buca
deduco tanti
guarda che è quello di ma non è rimasto
sul cornicione no pure isola che pirla
riuscito sì sì sì sì no ciccio ma vero
nell'altra mappa cribbio in counter
strike sono finito dai 97 mi ha
recuperato di un sunto di ok ho pensato
fatta in sette aspettare testo sinistra
trattata ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta in me non è
tenuta ad esso era sepolto fu proprio da
test ha dato una secca ha infatti
esempio avanti a me no non è vero
vi prego famigli partita può non mi far
ripartire all'inizio la vita fa schifo
guarda guarda guarda non ci credo
due punti devo fare quell'ultima devo
farla in due punti in meno di te i magi
questa è la base l'abbraccio oddio ho
paura jol.org gliel'ha fatta l'ho fatta
l'ho fatta come va però la buca è lì
dietro dove la fuga
nel video di loro
no no ti lascio fare e poi capisco ha
certo
complimenti se io la faccio a rimbalzare
sul muro e vali vinco se la centro 3
difficile se la faccia arrivare lì in
mezzo e per il tiro dopo centro siamo
pari appunto al pareggio appunto alla
vittoria io punto al pareggio
no no 06 la vita fa schifo guideri buona
iscritti iscrivetevi al cane di ciccio
il parco giochi ben descrizione ve li
lascio per ragazzi merita ciccio ha
meritato in questa partita mi ha battuto
ed è stato umiliante
io sono contento che ciccio abbiamo
partecipato in europa grazie a tempo
qualcosa di dirlo però i video sia
piaciuto spero che il canale vicino mi
piace perché oggi siete iscritti anche a
quello speriamo restante spero veramente
ragazza è stata esclusa tea diritto
scusate assistiti iscritti vabbè cosa
significhi lasciano poi mi piace quali
seguito da schizzare sociali si chiede e
noi ce li ha non possiamo mica quando
faremo le battagliere f io contro ciccio
ma che bello vederla bru beh ragazzi
[Musica]